Tyler's on the line hey Tyler how are
you dude are you doing Dave better than
I deserve what's up yeah so I'm 23 my
fiancee is 22 and we're getting married
in March
congratulations thank you very much and
we were fortunate enough to stumble upon
you and your plan shortly into our
engagement and it's truly an into the
prayer because we were really just kind
of scrambling trying to save for the
wedding and our personal finance was
over a mess so finding your plan really
helped us get focused so we were we
started with every dollar and both of us
since we're not married we have our
individual budgets and we work together
on making them but we both manage our
own finances still and good that's why
you have exactly yeah so we have shared
I have a bank account in my name and
basically we're using it as a savings
account for the wedding okay and we were
fortunate we've been blessed to come
into some money that is going to cover
all of our expenses for the wedding and
part of the honeymoon fun so where'd
that come from oh I'd rather not say but
I kind of fun it's fun it's from a
family source actually that's wonderful
yeah it's been a true blessing from God
I mean we're really just praying about
stressing out at first look at the
finances as I'm sure you're aware
weddings are expensive and it's a true
blessing so now we've got this is money
that we can apply towards the wedding
and the honeymoon I I just wanted to run
our plan by you and see what you think
so basically I want to save a continue
to save the money as if we didn't have
this blessing and act like we were gonna
pay for the wedding on our own that way
when the wedding actually continents
paid for we've got to stop some of money
sitting there that we can combine after
the wedding and the honeymoon everything
settled down we can sit down combine it
with any gifts that we get from the
wedding and throw it at our debt
snowball that we are both working on
individual thing wrong with just
throwing it towards that snowball now
that's what my question is do you think
it would be better to do it now yeah
sure now here's let me explain our debt
you we've got
she's got some student loan debt about
$8,000 I've got a I made the mistake of
two weeks before we found your your plan
I went out and bought a new car so I did
0% which I heard you talking about a
couple days ago but so our only debt is
her student loans in my car come on
desert flower how much your car tonight
two thousand ow okay and how much are is
in the wedding fund uh right now we're
looking at well $1,300 okay so that's
going to be your whole weddings thirteen
hundred bucks
no that's that's what we've saved right
now Oh what I'm asking is this the
family members dumping how much in there
Oh it'll be about five grand okay good
so check the wedding off check okay then
you work on your debt snowball she works
on her debt snowball until we're married
and when we're married we just check on
the debt we just keep we combine
everything at that point and finish off
whatever's done so my guess is you're
probably still going to owe on your car
she might be a little not counting us by
then but I don't know what you're making
but if you could both get them paid off
would be awesome but if there's any debt
left when you're married by either one
of you just combine your incomes combine
your monies and you attack the attack it
at that point but there's no reason to
not go ahead and attack them now okay
yeah I mean we're we're both Christians
and we you know we both agree and
keeping things separate before marriage
you know and we're actually we live an
hour and a half away from each other so
we're not even able to see each other
besides weekend so we are you know
following your plan and keeping our
finances separate not combining anything
before the wedding but my next question
was since since we are long-distance and
we we just can't spend you know but the
weekends together would you recommend we
still do FPU after the wedding yeah yeah
sure okay I mean lots of people do it
then but obviously it's a great free
marriage counseling process but you
could do it after as well either one
will work
amen thanks for calling in um you're
really thoughtful you've got some good
direction you're you're ahead of the
game for the average twenty
three-year-old you're doing really well
congratulations